bye
[Aplausos]
un ambiente de celebración
es lo que predomina en varias ciudades
de estados unidos luego de que varios
medios de comunicación y la agencia de
noticias ap dieran como ganador hay un
baile
pitos cacerolas gritos de felicidad son
las expresiones de los seguidores del
partido demócrata y este es uno de los
grandes días en la historia de eeuu
sabes realmente hemos probado que la
democracia ha ganado realmente que gran
día para el mundo y para todas las
personas de este país ese es realmente
un día especial diría que es el mejor de
mi vida
en washington desde que se conoció la
noticia cientos de personas se reunieron
a dos metros de la casa blanca banderas
de eeuu y pancartas a favor del electo
presidente adornaron una manifestación
marcada por la esperanza honestamente
siento como un tipo de alivio de que
esto finalmente terminó se siente como
si te hubieras quitado un peso de los
hombros sé que aún queda mucho por hacer
por nuestro país como con el senado la
corte suprema- un escenario similar se
registró en pensilvania en el estado que
le abrió la puerta de la oficina aduanal
demócratas creen que el de este sábado
es un resultado histórico
estamos muy emocionadas estamos muy
emocionadas eeuu hablo y hemos ganado
cada voto con todo creemos en nuestros
corazones que bailen es lo mejor para
eeuu las manifestaciones y las
expresiones de felicidad se extienden
por toda la unión americana